[Applause]
patience is not a virtue
it is a weapon
[Music]
what's your wow rabbit
well hennessey's make your move has
gotten off to a great start we had nate
hill defeat i am brandon
in the first matchup we heard from nas
we saw the great campaign
that has you in the spotlight maurice
but up next that may be our heavyweight
battle of the day
we have gizza and rizza battling it out
so maurice
first up we have rizza so you've known
both of these players for a long time
right
what can you tell us maybe a fun fact
about them
well the thing that's interesting to me
is the intensity level
of rizza i mean rizza is the kind of guy
who's
he's not here to crack jokes very
thoughtful
incredibly intellectual and he wants to
just get it done
and let me tell you you mess with him
you're going to get cut
so this is the kind of guy who you like
his attitude at the board
he brings out intensity he brings the
fire
and we should expect to see him really
show his stuff
in this game and he's the producer of
almost all of wu-tang clan's albums and
of course he's been a founding member so
he is
well known in the hip-hop industry and
he's been a real inspiration for many of
the
elite talents and he's also a
competitive chess player though right he
held the hip-hop chess federation belt
he started
uh the wuches.com and you know he just
he's a huge lover of the game of chess
i i don't think that anyone should
underestimate his strength
absolutely not are you kidding i mean
you're going to see a different game
than the one we just saw between these
two
they're going to bring the fire and
like you said he's really heavily into
it you know shout out to
adisa banyoko of the hip-hop chess
federation uh adisa
is cool cool brother doing his thing
helping the young people out in cali
and i really feel like rizza is
is somebody who feels like he needs to
get involved on the ground in order to
uh make a difference for sure and
speaking of helping the young people out
jizza who is the spiritual head if you
will of the wu-tang clan
he launched a program titled science
genius battles which motivates young
high school students to learn science
through hip-hop
to improve science education in new york
city of course he had the
legendary grand master's album which is
should be
a chess anthem for every single player
and
absolutely you know a nod to the highest
level achievement in chess
each song in the album had a theme of
chess play so clearly a chess lover
and he looks like a thinker just based
on that image that we have in front of
us a thinker
a scientist a philosopher is absolutely
all of that put together uh he brings
the intelligence he brings the acumen
and he brings the passion for change
as well as you see is his contributions
to the worlds and i got to give it up
for wuten that
they have used their credibility
uh their fame their notoriety to make a
difference
and it's a beautiful thing to have them
on doing this and the fact that they
want to help
such a beautiful cause as well no
accident whatsoever
and i'm really happy and proud to see
these brothers
continue to represent in the highest way
and the time has come it has indeed and
well giza gets the white pieces and it
looks like rizza
he is 2005 rated so wow
maurice you sure you want to take that
handicap against uh somebody like rizza
i'm sure i don't but wow i mean look at
that you already got the queen's gambit
in effect on the board uh c4 e6 i mean
these guys are not horsing around they
know
how to play and he knows to just grab
that pawn and c4
you're not gonna keep it anyway so
playing very solidly we'll see now
a total difference already knight f3 you
see this already between
the first game and this one you see
centralization
peace development so far very natural
i mean this could be a game between me
and you james
yeah really really i mean absolutely
we're gonna have to see what happens
here and actually get that game
actually to happen too i mean look at
this you know this pawn on c4 has been
hanging for a while but this is how
strong they are they know
you don't just take something that may
look free it's dangling in front of you
but that would give white better control
over the center by releasing this e2
pawn
up to e4 so that's why the tension has
been kept they often say that strong
players know when to keep the tension
and both these players coming out really
with some great strength
i'm really i'm really waiting for the
mistake and a3
that one is a slight unnecessary
slightly unnecessary move
at this point so one i was a little off
move
because the bishop is already on e7 so
it didn't intend to go to b4
so i would have anticipated knight c3 so
at least we've seen
slight off move at the moment not a big
deal but look at this
c6 semi semi slop territory guys
hit him with the semi inverted v
formation
right here this when you look at this
you say i don't know who's playing
is this magnus and levon
or is this razer gizza this is what we
want to know
well we we can hear their thoughts right
now we'll take a listen in and
i really hope that they're trash talking
each other i want to hear that
okay i must have missed that last move
and i realized you moved already
okay let me squeak up
in that case
i just wasted a minute thinking it was
your move
must have been the beat yeah it must
have been in a b i try my head
okay
let's do something different here
and in a continuing trend they were
completely silent when we tuned and they
just know
and they have that sense but they did
get a little bit uh
chattier as time went on and that was
funny to hear hey i didn't even realize
it was my move that happens to all of us
wasted a minute wasting a minute bro
he still has time he still has time on
the clock uh to handle it but
as you can tell this maneuver knight a6
knight c7 we would say is
less traditional uh in chess but
unorthodox to be sure the knight on c7
really would prefer to be on d7 it could
have gone there in one move
and we see not wasting any time trading
after age six
already we see a major difference have
we seen any blunders yet
no no we have we've seen any moves that
didn't at least
give a nod to the center of the board no
we're seeing all that we're not seeing
perfect play
we're not seeing grand master chess even
master level but we are seeing
good moves get played and these guys are
not just hanging pieces
i mean i'm this is going to be a very
interesting match whoever wins this is
going to be a very
interesting opponent for nate to be sure
given his level of play look at castling
early
white's pieces are just perfect i mean
the knight i may not have put on b3
but guys we're seeing the game who's
there's intentionality
in every single move and that's what's
every move both sides king safe
uh the only misplaced piece really i
mean i give white the nod here because
of the bishop on c8 and the knight on c7
but i wouldn't make i wouldn't bet any
money on who's gonna win this game
like zero i have no idea 95
do you see this centralizing the 90s
knight on e5
and you can't play f6 because the knight
g6 try it play f6 if you like
yeah i mean he knows he needs to get rid
of that knight though so he plays bishop
f6 understanding i shouldn't push the
pawn let me get the bishop here
all right now i'm curious to see the
next move this is going to say a lot
this very next
is going to say a lot because something
like 93 blunders heavily
if you drop the knight back to d3 f4
looks like an automatic move if you're
going to play knight e5
if you play if he plays f4 right now
then
you know i'm just going to start
practicing
the prep buttons you play a move like f4
it means you understand
you can spot that go
we'll see what the next move is uh you
know this
this is this is good stuff and f4 can be
a tough
move to play if you're not super
familiar with these kind of stone wall
pawn strikes with pawns on d4 and f4
solidifying the center he could be
thinking a little bit i was about to say
he could be thinking in a reactionary
manner by removing the knight from
attack but it still has a clear purpose
so even though
that's maybe not a move that we'd see
the magnus carlsons of the world play i
think it's a very good move
i actually like to move along definitely
pressuring that bishop on f6
and again one trade has occurred in this
entire game a bishop for a night no
pawns have been traded off there's no
premature moves being played now b6
played willingly parting
with the bishop on f6 so that he can get
his bishop into the game we're seeing
solid pawn formation no blunders nothing
this is a game
we've got to pay attention now to the
clock actually as a
factor in the game as well we certainly
do i think this one's going the distance
just based on the locked up
structure that we have here c5 trying to
break it open and then put a rook on c1
behind the pawn
and that's the good thing about knights
they're better closed positions if
there's open space
the bishops thrive but i think that giza
played a very good move there with c5
sorry answers certainly an interesting
move
and you just you see the thoughtfulness
as well i mean people are
are looking and saying aren't these guys
rappers and they're supposed to have a
certain kind of vibe
braggadocio and the like and you're
seeing
the rapper scientists like i said the
rapper philosopher
the thinker at work the mind you could
just see deep into the game they're not
even interested
in trash talking each other i think in
part because they're such
long time friends i mean it's i can
imagine it's very hard to start this in
your boy
you know like this is my boy i wait for
the next match
when i'm playing somebody i don't really
know and who i heard talk trash on me
as well because nate did call them out
so wait until they wait until they play
you maurice the trash
i'm definitely trash talking you can oh
man i'm just gonna have to egg them on
because i just want to hear them
freestyle
you know i really want to hear them show
their skills
because they're just such great
wordsmiths they have such wonderful
ideas
you know expressiveness so i really want
to have that come out not
not just to try to distract them but
here we see bishop e7 on the board
and again very solid game guys
positional
solid if i had white i'd feel
comfortable but i wouldn't say i was
winning or
even much better right you just have
more space but
why don't we hear their thoughts because
i i want them to talk to each other i
don't know if they are but let's take a
listen in very quickly don't look like
they're talking man
[Laughter]
we've been we've had bad luck next time
we switch let's make it short
unless they start says they start
talking but let's hear what they have to
say
okay
nice and serious
now you're talking serious business with
me
and i don't like it
yeah that's the quality
oh
well as both players let their moves do
the talking we have to
shout out and thank some of our huge
contributors here we had donations from
chesapeake and michelle thank you so
much
and just a reminder that uh you can
click on the donate button on chess.com
the about page
hennessey's pledge to match all
contributions to the chess.com twitch
channel
with the charity donation up to 250
000 so thank you so much to those who
have already donated and who will
continue to but
maurice james we have a very intense
chess game underway
where rizza put his pawn on f5 and
you know he tried to close down that
bishop and queen that were on the
diagonal
also guarding the e4 square making that
a very difficult break
and by the way did you see his move
queen e8 did you guys peak that
i saw it 96 threat and also the threat
to the c6 pawn so
he ain't big fella right just one move
it man and the queen was on d8
there was a threat if you just go back
one one move as well
it was a threat to either play knight g6
and potentially take your dark square
bishop
with knight g6 and also there was a
threat to take on b6
and pick off the pawn on c6 because the
knight would have
been attacking with the queen attack
uncovered that's a double threat
and the mere fact that he played queen
e8
come on guys that is a player
right that is somebody who sees moves
and he saw the move right there and then
he said it's time for your knight to
leave and here comes my queen into that
side
and okay his bishop really would like to
get away from b7
and be on e4 if you could just jump that
piece
all the way to e4 then you'll be able to
sweet square so he's still not really
threatening anything on that side
but i'm still wondering like what's
gonna happen in this game
i mean these guys are not blundering
they're playing solid chess
they're getting it done in this game and
again i'm going to say
a lot is going to hinge on the clock
management how to handle themselves when
we get to
just a down to a minute or two and how
they
handle that kind of time pressure
because right now
they're playing chess rizza definitely
had a great initiative swing here
especially after queenie ate the queen
g6 the knight was on e5
and then moved to f3 so he missed that
f4 move which could have probably
granted him a little bit more initiative
maybe followed by even g4 and start a
king side attack due to the locked up
bishop
on b7 but the problem is that he moved
it back to f3
moving the knight multiple times as
kappa blanket says you should refrain
from doing so is now uh under some
pressure i would think here
rizza could could swing this yeah it's
interesting because i do believe that
sometimes they're playing a little bit
reactionary
but they still have purpose in their
moves and well maurice knight to b5
i can capture that thing and try to open
up the c file push my pawn to c6
what do you think rizza has spotted here
and he has done so he did capture on
b5 but cece might be a mistake as a rook
c8
and now that was i was going to say that
now the question becomes
do you really want to do that move
because yes maybe you have this past
pawn but you got you're going to have
the business of having to hold on to
this pawn although
there is some kind of sacrifice of the
queen on
on b7 by capturing on b7 that's hyper
risky i'm trying to calculate it i don't
think it works
in fact sacrificing here because black
can probably just bring the queen back
to f7 and then the b pawn is going to
drop so
something to calculate but doesn't work
out for black
but look at the variations we're
analyzing you feel me i mean we're
actually looking at lines like that
variations right variations and he saw
it he didn't play c6
he played queen d3 hitting the b pawn
and now a capture on c5 c5 knight c5
hitting the ball
on on b7 the e pawn on e6 the b
pawn on b5 yeah in
the house follows the house stuff this
is this is
and how do you guard all of it there's
no way to guard all of that oh my
goodness
this is now a tangible advantage
and he could just grab it looks like the
pawn on b5
and it's again it's gonna be about the
clock they each at three minutes
and change three minutes 24 seconds
three minutes 22 seconds
this is now going to be a matter of
trying to manage the clock
and he did b4 he played b4
positions he didn't grab that right away
and he allowed
a6 now he still has an overwhelming
advantage these knights will spank these
bishops any day
especially that bishop on c8 is going oh
my goodness thanks for that dominant
knight
on c5 so he can easily double on the c
line
this is a game robert i would see you in
a tournament playing against
some master level player and just take
give them some lessons
and our point is that black can't really
move very easily every single move has a
consequence
you want to free this bishop on ca but
oh gosh i was about to say e5 runs into
pawn takes pawn
queen with a check
and the rook falls in the club i don't
know what to do here i don't know what
to say i'm about to jump out to see but
i got to sit down
so the moment he missed it he missed it
missed the tactical opportunity to win
at least a bishop at least in that
position
and instead because here after this move
you pointed out takes and
takes back on e5 queen takes would be
check bishop e6 might be
the only way to save your rook i would
imagine but
that's going to lose at least another
piece so
this was devastating this would have
been crushing and he missed it that
missed the tactic
and so that's we've seen at least as a
weakness on his part
and now suddenly black is the one who's
got some moves going maybe play f4
and go for it with the initiative on the
king's side missed the break he played
h5 this this game is up in the air guys
and
two minutes each one of them has on the
clock and i know i can tell that they
played each other many times before
just by the way that jesus reacting i'm
sure that rizzo has had some cool
sacrifices and winning
tactics against jesus and that's why
he's saying wait i don't want to be
attacked anyway i'm going to just play
a solid approach but right now it is
feeling like it's black's game for the
taking for rizza because as you said
maurice f4 comes in
that bishop slides into h3 that king on
g1 is awfully lonely over here
yeah big opportunity and also the bishop
on f6 can probably slide back to e7
and go to d6 and have a beautiful
diagonal there for the attack
did he actually play the move he played
bishop e7 yeah
oh my gosh see i i was i was thinking
like that's just high level
maybe he might not spot a retreating
move to reposition yourself
look that's a serious move and now black
has got f4 on tap
the bishops that i was just deriding
they're about to ride this position
to the sunset i mean this is beautiful
black is starting to show some stuff
white has to deal with the initiative
that's coming at him
f3 trying to maybe hold up this attack
not a bad idea actually because if he
gets an f4 he can shut the position down
and and black himself may not
necessarily want to play a four at this
moment
yeah clear he doesn't want to sit and
wait for rizzo to come attack him he's
saying
i'm not going down without a fight so oh
that queen's f3 watch out the d5 pawn
we've seen
that riz has overlooked that square once
in this game i don't think he's going to
miss it again
let's see here but it's a real threat
it's a real real threat
and this time hard to defend he's
already missed it oh my goodness i don't
know will he see queen takes d5
check a second time a second opportunity
that would be a devastating blow by the
way
jesus is down to 146 [__] it did see
he takes d5
why did it check wow what's on the board
hanging as well the king is under attack
this one is all day
courageous all day right now today
you know but it is getting into time
trouble so if i'm brazil i'm like yeah
just go
just go go f4 now you've got to make
moves now you've got to be quick
now you've got to rely on instinct and
will if he's being a bit ponderous right
now thinking about it
okay challenge the queen okay maybe not
it's
not it's not the best idea because queen
g3 and then bishop d6 is going to give
counterplay to black so i didn't like
weakening those dark squares
does he see the rook is hanging guys
this is the oh my god
right does he see it i'm telling you
there's something about this game that
tells me he has lost
and been checkmated by rizza a number of
times because that rook was hanging
he finally stole upon but i'm with you
i'm with you maurice that these dark
squares scare me so after queen g3
i don't think he's gonna go bring his
queen to the corner even though it's
a full rook okay we'll come back to the
gym okay queen back to g6 now let me
tell you something
that's a rook is a rook is a rook that's
a rook it's a rip
i mean f4 is still going to give some
counter play for black that's going to
be dangerous
and you're still going to have to
calculate that but i'd like i like
taking the rook and ff4
queen evil he didn't take the rook
he didn't take the rook he gave black
another chance
and now black can definitely bring the
bishop out to e6 save the rook
and the game continues but guess what
129 against 103 the clock is starting to
be a huge factor
somebody might lose on time i told you
guys this from the beginning right
right when you see logical moves like
this they're so thoughtful
that they might lose on the clock
they might they don't know how to get
this might get wild yeah this is only
down to 46 seconds
i think one player will lose on time and
not even realize it
that might be where we're going with
this good move though
bring that rook over that's his plan so
nice d3 look at the reroute
oh nice nice and instantly and now
they're starting to speed up
now i think they're feeling oh bishop h4
bishop h4 h4 looks
cool my goodness that's out easy have a
nice day
nice move the queen cannot counter
because mate
that's going to cost gizza a few seconds
to feel this position
look at that counter play razor just
through adam
hitting bishop h4 wow
or d2 only moves okay so he drops the
queen back
all right drop back still ahead on the
clock that's the good news for jizzy
even though he's dropping in exchange he
already was up a pawn
and his knights are about to dominate
the dark squares whoa whoa
no no no this man was too exuberant
sacrifices
with 28 seconds and now look at the
speed they're playing at but white has
two gorgeous
knights no way in the world this is
winning for white but will he do it in
time
as they are starting to play blitz use
the dark squares and let's listen and
hear their thoughts as we get down the
stretch here hopefully uh the players
can
provide some more entertainment than
they already are over the board
and that pawn is going really far so
they're both silent oh it's in my phone
dominant night move that's going to
leave a mark rook cakes
give me your rook with check and just as
owning this game right now
we can just protect this knight or move
it and this
this is all white right up two nights
with just a little bit of time left on
the clock
9.3 seconds i mean when they started to
play blitz it turned into
like a real slugfest they knew what
exactly what they were doing on the
blitz side as well they can play fast
when they need to
man jesus made he has missed some great
moves that win him the game
but he hasn't made any tremendous
blunders it felt like and he is just
gobbling up pawns that king on h6 should
be checked in just a few moves
yeah he could have won a rook it looks
like with rook g6 check would have been
game over but now rook
h5 is made
he has the chance again will he see it a
second time around he's got 40 seconds
left
on his clock and he has rook that's a
mate oh and he
left roman away he better hope like
flag is there that doesn't cost him
later
yeah that was a big miss here uh i think
that he's still
oh rick takes a four that was desperate
that's desperation
this is johnny ball game now he can just
start queening pawns
this is over he maybe he's hoping for a
stalemate all right well
i think they're talking so let's listen
in as their the game is about to
conclude
and they're jesus
you're talking
[Applause]
been a draw game the king has no legal
moves and he
didn't move oh my goodness
i don't think that do you think jesus
would have queen there
we have to ask them when we get them on
later correct we gotta x
unreal right at the moment when the trap
was
at its finest point and he didn't move
he ended up losing on time when he had
only one move on the board
and weaning would have stalemated with
no moves for
the king it cannot walk into check
despite having all that extra material
the game would have been a draw
and unfortunately for riza he didn't get
the chance
fortunately for us because i don't know
what happens in the case of a draw what
do we do
flip a coin like what would you have
done to the side of the champion
but i don't even know the answer that
but i do think that gizza was the worthy
winner
of that game oh absolutely he took it to
rizzo
he was too cautious we'll have to ask
him you know about their
playing history between the two of them
but it felt like he had a clear plan he
had a purpose
for almost all of his moves let me tell
you something
if you have to pick right now between
nate and gizza
that's gonna be a game that's gonna be a
game from what i just saw
i think giza could give him time odds
and still win wow
and still win you're even trash talking
nate right now
you know he's a buddy but if you just
look at what just happened here
look at the rating next to rizz's name
that doesn't happen by accident that is
a serious player
and gizza from the start of the game to
the finish
he looked like the guy who was in charge
had more time too
and more time very not his tactics
we would say not as sharp as they should
be but in terms of his strategic intent
the ability to harmonize forces get his
pieces into the game king
safety advancing pawns and when the
technical phase came by the way
the finish line the mop up operation and
then time to promote a pawn
i mean pure intent yeah he may not be a
grandmaster level player but he played
with grandmaster intent
all the way throughout he was very much
focused on what he wanted to get done
and he did it
kudos to him definitely the deserved
winner and when you're dropping albums
by the name of uh grandmasters
i think you gotta play like one every
now and then and he he polished him off
that was a pretty clean game
we should highlight that one move bishop
h4
by rizzo which was excellent and routed
his pieces that was
a really nice stuff so let me uh bring
that position up again
absolutely sterling move i think i mean
you see a move like that drop on the
board
and that's the thing about the level of
players right guys
they fight they might not play the most
accurate moves and then they play a move
like this you go whoa
who's playing black like right his level
hustle did he his husband the problem is
inconsistency because he played bishop
h4
and after queen f1 instead of pocketing
the exchange which by the way blacks
black is not winning white still has
compensation those knights are boss
pieces
but instead of pocketing exchange he
immediately blundered bishop takes g2
and his opponent was not frazzled he
took on g2 and that cost him both
bishops
against the very stable knights and that
turned into a big problem in this end
game is why
white ended up winning the game and
that's a sign of a very good player is
when you were
blunders aren't that bad for you like
jesus blunder
was still a pretty good looking position
he would have lost a rook for a bishop
and a pawn
and had those knights that were still
going to dominate so that is the sign of
an excellent player
and rizza 2 had some very good moments
it just felt like he was on his back
foot
out of the opening yeah these are
players that need
some more some more depth in their game
it's definitely some tactical
puzzles that they should be solving on a
regular basis to get
to get their eyes sharper but in terms
of
basic explanations if they said to james
uh
james could you give us some lessons
james couldn't be talking about well you
know you should be developing your
pieces
rook is worth five and the bishop is
word three they'll be like yo
uh-uh bring the real knowledge please
bring the candy knowledge because we
need the real deal because they can play
that's right yeah it was a very great
game today what we saw here in the in
the
end is where it really became uh like i
like to say for even magnus has time
trouble and when time trouble does
happen you are prone to make mistakes
here and i think time got to him he saw
him getting low
jesus is still up on time and then he
started to make mistakes there
and the rest is history it happens to
the best of us
it certainly does well we are going to
bring both of these players on
for a discussion and we of course want
to hear their thoughts
and we're just going to take a break now
but when we return we will have
rizza and jizza joining us for some fun
and some analysis
be right back
to defeat your opponent you must become
your opponent
what's your wow rabbit
[Music]
we are back and jizz and rizza in the
building
yo fellas that was exciting man that was
fun
that was an interesting game uh it was
it was
very solid at the start i know you guys
played each other
so many times over so many years tell me
first i'll start with you jizza what did
it feel like now
playing your man literally in front of a
big audience
online like i said it felt like we were
in the
world series of chess
what it felt like was because of knowing
that there's an audience watching us
so it's kind of intimidating in that
sense but
we're used to playing each other
and i'm questioning about that rizza
playing each other being so familiar
with each other's styles did you feel
that impacted the game
um yeah it kind of impacted the game
definitely in the beginning phase
you know when just does that that queen
gambit which is my
i hate that game um and normally
when he when he does that uh opening i'm
always facing some type of difficulties
but playing him so many times i felt
prepared for it
but i see that uh his kung fu was better
than mines today
now i feel you the game was very solid
from the beginning
we we go through the moves and we were
just rapping about it
and saying all these moves look like
grandmaster moves we can't even tell the
difference between you guys
and top level players mostly in the
opening your knight a6 putting the
knight on the side and swinging it to
the middle
that was unorthodox to be sure but
nothing to say it was really bad
but is that how your games usually go
very solid like this
giza you you handle this so deliberately
like you you didn't want to go for the
attack right away you just seem to be
building up the space slowly but surely
well you know um playing with rizzo he's
a very patient
player and usually i i'm i'm quick to
make moves
before really thinking it out sometimes
especially when we're playing on a clock
we're playing some type of
blitz game and and i haven't played the
queen's gamut with him
in a long time so this is the first time
in a while i said you know because he
usually
have an answer for it um the last few
times i i tried it with him
but i just went for it this time you
know and rizza you you had this position
as we start building forward we just go
a little bit ahead it was very solid
everybody castled and and uh you chased
the knight out of the position
as well at what point did you feel as we
move
fast forward that maybe you were having
some difficulties in the position
because his pieces were starting to look
lively i think i felt the most
difficulty
when uh when i kind of blundered and
opened up the check for the attack on
the rook
um i can't see the screen right now what
you guys are looking at but
that attack on the rook um was the first
like punching the rib for me but then i
saw my position and i saw my bishops
also had strength to
potentially get a mate out of them and
so
i wasn't really devastated by it but
what
got once once he started you know you
know joseph was very patient he was
squeezing he was kind of squeezing me
there
um but i did uh i felt that if he came
if he removed this queen and went up
that foul to take the rook
i had a couple of answers for that right
you got some counter play trying to
attack him now
i'm curious gizza why didn't you gobble
on that rook i mean the rook was sitting
right there
it takes a lot i mean that was just
something i obviously overlooked
you talking about the rook that was at
a8 yes exactly
yeah i obviously over over overlooked
that or i would have captured it i
didn't
i didn't realize it until i made the
next move went
because i pushed the pawn up attacking
the queen right
right then then when once he
moved retreated with the queen i made a
i made the next move and then after
making that move i realized that the
rook was already open to be captured so
it was something that
i didn't even see by the way are you
looking at a chessboard right now
i'm looking at the one that's on the
screen wherever you are okay because i
was
wondering if you were actually doing all
this from the memory
but i can i can see yeah i can see the
setup okay i'll see
you right here as well all right so
that's after the
queen retreated after attacking exactly
h3
right yeah you attacked him with h3
right and then
i just noticed after i moved i forgot
the move i made after that did i move
the
you move your queen back and then he
saved his rook i believe a rook right
i moved the queen back and then he saved
then he saved the rook
and then after i moved again he did
bishop to b7
yeah because that was the winning move
right there
you played yeah now explain to me after
queen f2 you played this
spectacular shot bishop h4 we were super
excited about it
when the queen dropped back you didn't
take the rook you decided to
play bishop takes g2 why did you do that
well my clock
so in the beginning of the game i think
i made a you know i came in dancing
right had my beat machine
and so i lost maybe about 30 40 seconds
not even knowing that he made a move
right
right and they caught up with me at the
end so when i when i looked at my clock
i was like wow
i'm down to 36 seconds which is 36
chambers but
then at 36 seconds uh i basically
went into that panic mode of of of the
about
when we play each other on the clock we
got a slogan we use
called blowing up like like the bomb is
about to blow up
and so i felt the pressure of the bomb
and so instead of of course taking the
world first he catches back
and then maybe sacrificing uh queens and
all that and putting myself in a better
position
if i would have had another minute i
would have did it i would have made that
decision
but based on the pressure i was like
maybe i could get him to
spin some of his clocks and maybe it'll
become a time game
and he didn't fall for it at all i love
the way you guys describe chess
i love the the lingo you use uh of
course at the end
it was great technique on the part of
gizza and he ended up
getting this done so congratulations
great game we really
were entertained by it i'm gonna bring
in my boys robert
gm robert hess and masterman
james canty so they can come on in and
join the party we had a lot of fun
but i know they asked some questions for
you for sure
first of all that was an awesome game
you two clearly are quite good and
i could tell you've had many battles
between you
my first question i guess for you uh
gizza
is when and where did you learn to play
chess well
i've learned to play chess many many
years ago i was taught
by a cousin of mine when i was really
really young
but uh i was only taught uh the names of
the pieces and their movements
so that's the first time i learned how
to play chess
and then i didn't begin to play to many
many years later
maybe 91 92 when i started playing with
master killer
i was reintroduced to the game so that's
when i officially started playing chess
although i knew how to move the pieces
and the names of the pieces
i officially started playing around 92
with master killer
and what about you rizza well i had the
privilege of
uh you know growing up in a hood and had
a young lady who lived upstairs for me
i was about 11 years old and she taught
me how to play chess and took my
virginity
and so i had the process of you know
practicing chess and practicing man at
the same time and
i love the game ever since you can see
why
good memories yeah all right there's a
question for you rizza you once said
hip-hop
is a ba is a is a battle game and chess
is a battle so in your eyes what are the
parallels between the two
and how has chess influence your music
well you know chess definitely is a
battle it's a war
and you know hip-hop started with the
foundation of
dj battles break dancing battles best
graffiti tags and of course
mc battles so that warrior spirit
exists in chess and exists in martial
arts and it exists in hip-hop
and you know chess is affecting my life
in the sense of
regardless of of whether players are
good or not
chess makes you think analytically you
have to look ahead
and most times we find ourselves in
trouble is because we didn't think twice
or three times about the problem before
we face it very good thank you
and uh jizz i got a question for you uh
next month marks the 25th anniversary of
liquid swords
which is i mean honestly considered by
many to be a masterpiece
uh chess is woven throughout the lyrics
so what's it about the game that
inspires your
creativity and drive to achieve
greatness
um many different things um you know to
reflect back on what rizzo was saying
chess is a game of uh it's a battle
um you can re uh resembles war
you have many different pieces on the
board that does different movements
you know and hip hop when we started
rhyming many years ago we used to
walk across all through the borough
battling mc's challenging
these style and sharpening our swords
against one another um it's it's a
strategic game it's tactical
planning moves ahead just as in rhyming
you know
you plan ahead if you're about to battle
someone
you you you're watching what they do and
then you're studying their style and
their structure
and then you're writing for that and
preparing for the game or the battle
itself so
they kind of uh parallel each other in
such a sense
for sure um yeah i mean
it makes a lot of sense rizza how about
you i mean how have the skills you've
developed from chess
helped you push the limits of your
potential well
i'm you know even in the business i try
to think ahead and try to calculate
and then one thing about chess i think
that really resonates with me is that
you know you're you're you know you're
governing
multiple pieces so you know as a movie
director or producer
you're dealing with different musicians
different personalities and you're
out for one goal and that goal means you
kind of got to have this octopus
brain in all reality and chess to me
trains that for me
it trains it trains this multi i call it
multivision
it trains the multivision potential
inside of me as a creator
and so whether you know i've seen myself
be on movie sets and
having a tough day and at lunch time i
may go play a game of chess at lunch
you know i mean i have one of my buddies
reverend william burke
he'll be on the set and he'll be waiting
in the trailer for
for lunch and i'll come in lunch and
i'll play and i'll think and it'll
exercise those muscles and i go back out
and i try to
face the problem that's in front of me
beautifully said absolutely beautifully
said chest
as relaxation and stimulation but i'm
gonna say
jizza you've won that game but there was
a little bit of trash talking from your
next opponent nate hill he we asked him
what he was looking forward to projects
and the like he said i'm just looking
forward to
who i'mma beat next when risen just a
play
what are your thoughts about him trash
talking you guys right out the gate he's
not even played you yet
it's all good sometimes it's part of the
game you know and
there's a lot of trash talking in mostly
all competitions
even in sports you know boxers trash
talk each other before they jump in the
ring
and sometimes the trash talker get
trashed
[Laughter]
hey just i should have bit your ear that
fight right there though
yeah i was like man i call it it was in
the room
sometimes we'd be playing and you know
you know we we're family so
we'll be playing and it might get so
tough you might just
turn the pieces over like yo forget it
and just walk away with the
with the uh with the defeat but i will
you know as i pass the mic back to you
guys i definitely want to say this
this has uh been a unique experience for
me um you know national chess day is
something that uh
i'm happy to be a part of in our reality
and happy to be invited here
on this platform and and you know the
chess community
um i think the chess community sometimes
is not all-inclusive
you know what i mean and this feels like
a very inclusive advance i want to thank
you guys for inviting us to it
no problem no problem uh over to you how
many members
of wu-tang clan play chess and are there
any particular tense chess battle
stories
um myself rizza
master killer method man plays
uh he knows how to play but he doesn't
really play a lot i mean i haven't seen
him on the board
in years but he knows how to play the
game
the rebel lioness inspector deck plays
i said master killer right mathematics
oh a lot of mathematics plays our dj
and um that's that's pretty much it i've
never seen you guard playing rayquan
or ghost face killer
yeah but we've had many many games
uh between myself rizza and master
killer and a lot of times there's
there's some you know
with me and master killer there's a lot
of trash talking going back and forth
playing so long for so many years i i
think i played the most games with him
than anybody so there's always this
competitive thing
with us when it when it comes to chess
yeah
who has the better score um
we we go back and forth we go
like when i play master killer we
usually play uh
12 games we do it like a boxing um
fight like a 12 rounds of boxing yeah
and then sometimes it can be really bad
it could be nine
to three in my favor and sometimes it
could be nine three in his favor
sometimes wow
six sometimes just eight four it just
goes it goes back and forth
and wow you guys have a really good team
you guys could feel the team for a
serious chess tournament
yeah really though you got a squad i
want to see wutan versus
uh the streamers like that whole match
bring
bring four of them versus for the
streamers and see what's on wu-tang
yep
risk it all uh well
guys gotta have one more question for
you for the time being before we
just you got another game to play uh but
uh you both are
cultural icons and hip-hop legends you
push the limits in your mind to build
long-lasting legacies what has been
your greatest life lesson usually you go
first
greatest life lesson oh man there's been
there's been several of those um
damn what has been my greatest life
lesson
that's one of those hard questions to
answer man because you get old enough
man you have a lot of lessons in life
i would say to learn all you can learn
yeah i'm
not gonna ask it out you know i answered
that question with the blessing of uh
you know for those who don't know us you
know we we
um deal with knowledge of ourselves
right
and the enlightener the person who told
me to seek knowledge of myself
is actually jizza you know i mean um so
he
gave me a spark you know back at the age
of 11
and told me to seek knowledge of myself
and study
and i never stopped studying from that
day you know
never stop studying and it's always
thank him
as being uh the the spark that lit my
candle
because once my candy was lit i was able
to light so many others so
you know to the just the jizzer in the
building
by here